.
Welches Wasser trinkt ihr Zuhause?
Leitungswasser?
Mineralwasser aus dem Supermarkt?
Bevor ich in diese Wohnung hier
gezogen bin,
hab ich immer nur
Leitungswasser getrunken.
Nur: dieses Leitungswasser...
...schmeckt mir nicht.
Das war im Sommer.
Inzwischen bin
ich wieder umgestiegen
und hab mir währenddessen viele
Gedanken zu Leitungswasser gemacht.
Ich kenne ein paar Leute,
die sich sehr gut
mit Leitungswasser auskennen.
Das sind Sven, Anna und Patrick.
Die 3 arbeiten
im Zentrallabor von Hessenwasser.
Ihr Job ist es, die Qualität
des Leitungswassers
im Rhein-Main-Gebiet
sicherzustellen.
Sven und Anna
kenne ich schon länger,
wir haben damals in Mainz
zusammen Chemie studiert.
Und viel gemeinsame Zeit
im Labor verbracht.
Jetzt habe ich sie mal
in ihrem Labor besucht.
Ich will in diesem Video
folgende Frage stellen:
Wie gut ist
das deutsche Leitungswasser?
Was ist mit Schwermetallen,
Krankheitserregern, Mikroplastik,
Medikamentenresten?
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
dass es so einiges gibt,
das ihr noch nicht
zu Leitungswasser wisst.
Also, setzt euch,
macht es euch bequem.
Holt euch ein Glas Leitungswasser!
Oder auch nicht.
Bevor es ans Eingemachte geht,
erst mal ein paar Basics:
Unser Leitungs- und Trinkwasser
kommt aus verschiedenen Quellen.
Aus buchstäblichen Quellen,
aber auch aus Talsperren
und vor allem aus Grundwasser.
Schmeckt Leitungswasser nicht,
kann das am
persönlichen Geschmack liegen.
Aber auch am Mineralgehalt.
Der Mineralgehalt kann
je nach Quelle des Wassers
unterschiedlich hoch sein.
Dazu zählt auch die Wasserhärte:
Der Kalkgehalt.
- Das sind vor allem
härtebildende Minerale.
Da sind Calcium
und Magnesium zu nennen.
Die werden aus dem Gestein gelöst,
Kalkgestein im Untergrund.
Das heißt, es fällt Regen.
Der Regen ist mit CO2 versetzt.
Das bildet dann
im Untergrund Kohlensäure.
Diese Kohlensäure
löst dann das Kalkgestein auf.
Das fördern wir dann
mit unseren Brunnen wieder,
und finden es letztlich
auch bei uns im Trinkwasser wieder.
- Ist es ungesund,
hartes Wasser zu trinken?
- Grundsätzlich passiert gar nichts.
Wenn wir viel Calcium zu uns nehmen,
reicht es immer noch nicht aus,
um unseren Nährstoffhaushalt
damit zu decken.
Nur in unseren Wasserkochern und
Kochtöpfen kann es nervig werden.
Aber es lässt sich ja wieder beheben
und ist nicht gesundheitsschädlich.
Damit ihr ein Gefühl dafür bekommt:
mit nur 100 g Emmentalerkäse
nimmt man bereits genauso viel
Calcium und Magnesium zu sich,
wie mit 10 Litern Wasser.
Verkalken kann man
hierdurch schon mal nicht.
Hartes Wasser kann sogar Vorteile
haben:
- Häufig rufen Leute bei uns an,
die sich über Metalle
in ihrem Trinkwassers Sorgen machen.
Meistens geht es um Blei.
Da ist wiederum Kalk im Wasser.
Eine gute Sache,
denn das bildet eine Schutzschicht
in der Rohrleitung,
die wiederum verhindert, dass sich
Metalle aus der Rohrleitung
in das Wasser hinein lösen können.
Vor allem bei Blei liegt
der erlaubte Grenzwert tief.
Denn Blei ist
ein Nerven- und Blutgift.
Besonders gefährlich
für Schwangere und Kleinkinder.
Dummerweise wurden früher
Wasserleitungen aus Blei verlegt.
Heute zum Glück nicht mehr.
Bleirohre gibt es nur in Häusern
geben mit einem Baujahr vor 1973.
- Wir untersuchen häufig für die
Leute ihre Trinkwasserinstallationen
auf Blei und weitere Metalle
wie Zink und Eisen.
Es kommt ganz selten vor, dass mal
der Grenzwert überschritten wird.
- Falls ihr euch doch unsicher seid
mit Schwermetallen
im Leitungswasser,
kriegt ihr die Infos entweder
beim zuständigen Gesundheitsamt.
Oder bei eurem lokalen
Wasserversorgungsunternehmen.
Hausbesitzer und Wasserversorger
sind übrigens dazu verpflichtet,
Bleirohre auszutauschen, wenn
der Grenzwert überschritten wird.
Aber das gruselige
an Leitungswasser ist doch,
dass es, bevor es
aus dem Wasserhahn rauskommt,
durch ein riesiges
Rohrleitungssystem fließt,
das ich nicht sehen kann.
Was weiß ich, was in den Tiefen
der Rohre herumkriecht und wächst?
- Man darf sich das nicht so
vorstellen, dass das Wasser darin
die ganze Zeit steht.
In den Hauptleitungen fließt es
konstant die ganze Zeit.
Es wird immer
irgendwo was verbraucht.
Zur Not werden auch Rohre gespült,
um genau das zu gewährleisten.
In dem Hauptwassernetz
ist das Wasser immer in Bewegung.
Um genau das zu verhindern,
was man sich eben vorstellt,
dass dort irgendwie eben Leben
entsteht oder Leben wächst.
- Stehende Gewässer
sind viel einladender
für mikrobiologisches Leben
als fließendes Wasser.
Hinzu kommt, dass in unseren
Wasserleitungen auch keine Sonne
und keine Luft
und auch wenig Nährstoffe sind.
Also schlechte Bedingungen
für Leben.
Nur eins muss man sich klarmachen:
steril ist dieses Wasser nicht!
In diesem Glas, auf meiner Haut,
auf meinen Klamotten:
überall leben
ganz viele Mikroorganismen.
Aber die sind harmlos.
Damit sich unter
diese harmlosen Mikroorganismen
nicht mal Bösewichte mischen
wie z.B. Durchfallerreger,
gibt es inzwischen auch immer
bessere Nachweismethoden,
um die Qualität des Wassers
zu gewährleisten.
Falls ihr doch mal
länger nicht daheim wart
und Bedenken habt, dass das Wasser
in den Rohrleitungen länger stand:
- Hahn aufdrehen,
das Wasser laufen lassen!
Sobald man mit dem Finger merkt,
es wird bedeutend kälter,
dann kann man das
bedenkenlos trinken.
- Jetzt sollten wir uns mal
Gedanken machen:
Nicht ums Wasser,
das aus dem Wasserhahn rauskommt,
sondern auch um das Wasser,
das in den Abfluss reinfließt.
Alles,
was wir den Abfluss runterspülen,
landet in den Kläranlagen.
Und alles, was in den Kläranlagen
nicht geklärt werden kann,
landet in der Natur.
In letzter Zeit
reden alle über Mikroplastik.
Also kleinste Plastikartikel.
Der Großteil des Mikroplastiks
kommt von großem Plastik.
Plastikmüll, der tonnenweise über
unsere Flüsse in die Meere gelangt
und dort mit der Zeit, weil sich
Plastik eben nicht zersetzt,
einfach kleingerieben wird,
bis es Mikroplastikpartikel sind,
die dann auch wieder
in unserer Nahrungskette landen.
Aber wir spülen auch Mikroplastik
unseren Abfluss herunter,
und zwar nicht nur
über Kosmetikartikel.
- Unsere Kleidung besteht ganz
wenig nur noch aus Baumwolle,
also aus natürlichen Stoffen,
sondern, die meiste Kleidung,
die wir tragen,
besteht aus Polyester.
Zumindest aus Anteilen von Polyester
oder anderen synthetischen Fasern.
Gerade bei Funktionskleidung,
aber auch bei dem T-Shirt,
was wir jeden Tag tragen, sind
eben synthetische Fasern enthalten,
die dann zum größten Teil
in der Waschmaschine
aus der Kleidung rausgetragen werden
und so in unser Abwasser
gelangen können.
- Und damit auch wieder
in unsere Flüsse.
Aber wie viel Mikroplastik
landet da jetzt genau?
Anna ist Analytikerin.
Man stellt sich oft vor,
dass Chemiker im Labor
nur Sachen herstellen.
Aber Anna macht was anderes,
sie analysiert und charakterisiert.
Und das ist überhaupt nicht trivial.
Wenn ich die Stoffe
mit bloßem Auge nicht sehen kann,
wie soll ich herausfinden,
was ich hier vorliegen hab?
Dazu braucht man physikalische
und chemische Messmethoden.
Aber gerade bei Mikroplastik
ist das gar nicht so einfach.
- Wenn wir uns vorstellen,
uns interessiert,
wie viel Mikroplastik ist
in unserem Oberflächenwasser,
im Fluss enthalten?
Wir nehmen also
mehrere Liter Oberflächenwasser
und haben dann eine Sammlung
aus den Mikroplastik-Partikeln,
aus allem,
was da sonst noch drin rumschwimmt,
also auch aus natürlichen Stoffen,
Holzstückchen, Steinchen, Algen.
Wir müssen die Plastikartikel von
den anderen Partikeln erst trennen.
- Ihr könnt euch schon denken,
mit einem einfachen Sieb oder Filter
funktioniert das nicht.
Zumal es auch so viele verschiedene
Plastiksorten gibt. Und:
- Wenn ich im Labor eine Probe
analysieren und untersuchen möchte,
kann es sein, dass mein Oberteil,
in dem synthetische Fasern sind,
meine Probe kontaminiert.
Am Ende sehe ich im
Mikroskop eine synthetische Faser,
die ist aber gar nicht aus
der Probe gekommen, sondern von mir.
Man muss sehr reine Bedingungen
auch im Labor schaffen.
- Im kleinen Maßstab kein Problem,
im großen Maßstab echt tricky.
Sven beschäftigt sich seit
seiner Doktorarbeit mit Analytik.
Er warnt noch vor was anderem:
- Auf gar keinen Fall Medikamente
die Toilette runterspülen!
Genau aus dem Grund:
Das ist tatsächlich immer noch
ein allgemeines Problem.
Dass viele Leute meinen,
ich kann ja meinen Hustensaft
oder meine nicht auf gebrauchten
Pillen einfach die Toilette runter,
und dann sind sie weg.
Die lösen sich darin auf.
Am Ende geht das wieder
in den Wasserkreislauf zurück.
Das Problem ist, dass manche dieser
Inhaltsstoffe sehr unzureichend
bis gar nicht abgebaut
werden auf dem Weg.
- Wobei man hier wie so oft auch
nicht verallgemeinern kann.
Medikament
ist nicht gleich Medikament.
Das Schmerzmittel Aspirin lässt sich
biologisch recht leicht abbauen.
Das Schmerzmittel Diclofenac
allerdings,
das ist in Voltaren und anderen
Salben drin, auch in Tabletten,
das lässt sich biologisch
nicht so leicht abbauen.
Selbst im Körper wird es
nur teilweise verstoffwechselt.
Der Rest wird
unverändert ausgeschieden.
- Es landet in der Toilette.
Es wird runtergespült.
Es landet aber natürlich auch
über die Dusche,
wenn ich mir das
als Salbe draufschmiere,
auch da geht nur ein ganz geringer
Prozentsatz wirklich in die Haut
und wird verwendet,
der Rest wird einfach abgespült,
landet wieder im Abwasser
und kommt in die Kläranlage.
Landet also am Ende wieder
in der Natur. Unverändert.
- Die biologische Abbaubarkeit
ist das eine.
Die Mobilität ist das andere.
Wenn ein Stoff
jetzt sehr polar ist,
sprich, er versteht sich gut
mit Wasser,
dann wird dieser Stoff
leicht mit dem Wasser mitgetragen
und auf der ganzen Welt verteilt.
- Es gibt Studien,
die von Menschen gemachte Substanzen
in Gletschereis finden
oder in der Antarktis.
Das sind genau solche Substanzen,
die am Ende über den ganzen Erdball
verteilt werden
und so auch ein ökologisches Problem
sein können.
- Bevor ihr jetzt denkt:
oh mein Gott!
Konzentrationen, die Analytiker
wie Sven oder Anna
im Labor feststellen können,
sind winzig klein.
Die Messtechniken haben sich hier
auch stark weiter entwickelt.
- Stellt euch
'en sehr großen See vor!
Den Bodensee in Baden-Württemberg.
Wenn ich dort einen Zuckerwürfel
in diesen See schmeißen würde:
von der Substanz
könnte ich den nachweisen.
Das ist der Mikrogramm- und obere
Nanogramm-pro-Liter-Bereich.
Wir kommen noch viel weiter runter:
Wenn ich diesen Zuckerwürfel
noch kleinhaue
und nur ein Zuckerkristall nehme
und dies in den Bodensee schmeiße,
dann kann ich das
immer noch nachweisen.
- Aber je länger wir einen Stoff
in die Natur einbringen,
desto mehr häuft er sich
dort auch an. Deswegen:
- Auf gar keinen Fall Medikamente
die Toilette runterspülen.
- Vorsicht ist besser als Nachsicht.
- Es gibt eventuell auch Substanzen,
die wir in die Natur einbringen,
von denen wir noch gar nicht
wissen, dass sie ein Problem sind.
Die dann in der Zukunft eventuell
ein Problem sein können,
weil wir das
durch wissenschaftliche Studien
irgendwann untermauern können,
dass das, was wir vielleicht
lange als unschädlich
oder unproblematisch gehalten haben,
in Zukunft ein Problem sein könnte,
was wir jetzt noch gar nicht wissen.
- Anstatt zu warten, bis ein neuer,
kritischer Stoff identifiziert wird
oder bis irgendwelche
Grenzwerte überschritten sind,
versucht Sven jetzt schon Stoffe
und Konzentrationen zu beobachten,
und so die Analytik
vorausschauend einzusetzen.
- Prävention statt Reaktion.
- Zuhause trinken die 3 natürlich
auch Leitungswasser.
- Ich trink Wasser aus
meinem persönlichen Sprudler
immer von Zuhause aus.
Ich wohn im vierten Stock.
Da muss ich auch
keine Kisten mehr schleppen.
Aber seitdem ich weiß,
wie streng es kontrolliert wird,
sehe ich gar keine Veranlassung,
normales,
abgepacktes Wasser zu kaufen.
- Gesundheitlich ist es einwandfrei.
Aus ökologischer Sicht
ist es ganz klar besser.
Am Ende ist es
eine Geschmacksfrage.
- In Deutschland haben wir
die Trinkwasserverordnung.
Und die ist eine der strengsten
Reglementierungen, die wir kennen.
Das sorgt quasi dafür,
dass unser Trinkwasser auch
um Welten besser ist, als es...
nee, das kann ich nicht sagen.
(Gelächter im Hintergrund)
- Na, sagen wir so: um Welten
besser ist ein bisschen übertrieben.
Aber im globalen Vergleich
ist das deutsche Leitungswasser
ganz vorne mit dabei.
Deutsches Leitungswasser unterliegt
strengeren Qualitätskriterien
als das Mineralwasser im Supermarkt.
Es stecken viel Arbeit,
Sorgfalt und Wissenschaft
hinter der Qualität dieses Wassers,
das wir zu Hause einfach so
aus unserem Hahn bekommen.
Ich finde, das ist ein Privileg,
das wir wertschätzen sollten. Prost.
Welche Fragen
sind für euch noch offen?
Fändet ihr es gut, wenn wir künftig
mehr Experten interviewen?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Nicht weggehen,
ich habe noch eine coole Adcard.
Viele haben es schon mitbekommen
über Social Media:
Mir wurde der
Georg-von-Holtzbrinck-Preis
für Wissenschaftsjournalismus
überreicht.
Und ich möchte euch was zeigen
von der Preisverleihung:
Nämlich meine Laudatio.
Ulrich Blumenthal
vom Deutschlandfunk
hat meine Laudatio gehalten.
Und anstatt eine Rede zu halten,
hat er ein Video gemacht.
Obwohl er vorher noch nie
ein Video geschnitten hat.
Es ist der Hammer. Er hat jedes
MaiLab-Video sich angeschaut.
Er hat sich das Schneiden
selbst angeeignet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sich jemals
jemand schon so viel Mühe
für eine Laudatio gemacht hat.
Und das Video ist so geil
geworden. Schaut es euch an!
Wir haben es ungelistet verlinkt.
Das obere Video ist es.
Geht hin,hinterlasst Ulli Blumenthal
ein paar Kekse für seine Mühe.
Wir sehen uns nächsten Donnerstag.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher!